[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend willkommen zu
heute live seit heute gelten sie die
strengen corona maßnahmen schließen
müssen unter anderem gleich mehrere
bereiche cafés restaurants bars und
kneipen das sieht man auch bilder zu und
auch die tourismusbranche ist
betroffenen touristische übernachtungen
in hotels und in pensionen sind ab heute
nicht mehr erlaubt wir haben uns jetzt
heute abend mal die gastronomie
herausgepickt um beispielhaft über die
probleme dieses teil lockdown zu
sprechen und das tun wir mit alexander
herrmann
er ist bekannter fernsehkoch und
sternegastronomie sogar mit zwei
michelin sternen ausgezeichnet und
betreiber eines hotels in oberfranken
und dort befindet er sich auch gerade
genau genommen in wirsberg einen schönen
guten abend herr hermann hermann was
wäre denn sicherlich noch ja sie hört
mich wunderbar ich sehe jetzt gerade von
ihnen nur noch ein standbild aber wir
hören uns was wäre denn jetzt heute
abend um sie herum jetzt will ich auch
das bild wieder los wenn jetzt kein
lockdown wäre wie müssen wir uns die
situation bei ihnen gerade vorstellen
also ganz klar an einem montagabend ist
sicherlich nicht der reichste tag in
form von gäste vielfalt aber es ist
reges reger betrieb und wir haben
wirklich zu tun aber uns erwischt
natürlich jetzt diese lokalen eiskalt
und genauso fühlt sich auch gerade mein
hotel und die restaurants an es ist
wirklich irgendwie auch von der oder
eiskalt was halten sie denn sie haben
quasi schon ein bisschen vorweggenommen
was halten sie denn von den seit heute
geltenden maßnahmen
naja es gibt ja da zwei dinge dass eine
es gibt da die herz wirkung und die hirn
wirkung also mein herz war natürlich
total enttäuscht weil wir in den letzten
monaten wie in der gastronomie also ich
kann ja auch für meine betriebe reden
wir haben uns so viel mühe gegeben diese
hygienemaßnahmen so umzusetzen und ich
meine wenn jemand hygiene kann die
gastronomie die gute gastronomie wächst
damit ja auf wir können das wir haben
wirklich alles gegeben und das hat mit
leidenschaft und kraft haben wir die
letzten wochen und monate diesen karren
der last der in diesem frühjahr durch
lockdown waren haben wir versucht wieder
rauszuziehen und dann kommt eben der die
sogenannte hirn enttäuschung wir dazu
weil genau in diesem moment nun so darf
ich sagen habe ich es empfunden dass wir
in der gastronomie mehr oder weniger ein
teil des hygiene konzepts deutschland
sind weil bei uns alles kontrolliert war
selbst das lka sagte
wir wären keine pandemie treiber
dementsprechend hat mich das natürlich
in herz hören über halt total kalt
erwischt wir sprechen gleich nochmal
über die hygiene konzepte auch in der
gastronomie
doch vielleicht vorher nochmal gefragt
so ganz allgemein können sie trotzdem
nachvollziehen dass die gastronomie dort
runter gefahren würde ich meinen das
problem ist ja im prinzip auf der hand
liegen zum einen treffen sich dort
relativ viele menschen auf einem raum
zum anderen ist es natürlich auch so
dass das ja auch andere branchen
betrifft also nicht nur die gastronomie
aber eben auch sie also im grunde ja ich
verstehe den gedanken zu sagen man
trifft sich ja viel und deswegen
behaupte ich jetzt auch sind wir ein
wenig bitte verzeihen sie mir die
wortwahl ein wirtschaftliches
bauernopfer denn wenn man theater kino
und gastronomie schließt dann können die
leute noch zwei sachen machen gefühlt
einkaufen und zur arbeit gehen und
danach bleibt nicht viel jetzt ist es
aber so dass ich diese form von ich
nenne es mal provokant auch
kontrollverlust ein wenig kritisch sehe
denn jetzt wenn die leute nicht ins
kontrolliert zum essen gehen können dann
bleibt ihnen haushalten und sie waren ja
nicht glauben dass in den kommenden vier
wochen vielleicht auch sechs die leute
immer brav so zu hause sitzen werde
da glaube ich leider nicht daran weil es
uns jetzt ja auch vorher schon
funktioniert wo man vielleicht auch in
den ein oder anderen ort ein bisschen
lax mit den regeln umgegangen ist das
müssen wir jetzt ausbaden das heißt ich
verstehe den hebel warum man bei uns
sagt wir unterbinden ein wenig oder
geschäftliches wirtschaftliches ein
berufliches tun um eben jetzt erstmal so
ein blog rein zu bringen um eben diese
welle zu unterbrechen
aber glauben sie mir das tut weh und ob
ich das jetzt gut heiße oder nicht naja
herrmann wir genau versuchen auch immer
unsere zuschauer unsere user mit
einzubeziehen
da schreibt zum beispiel auf youtube.de
ich bin so sauer auf die leute die nicht
aufpassen konnten darunter leiden müssen
jetzt jene die hygiene konzepte
entwickelt und alles richtig gemacht
haben apropos sauer
vielleicht gerade auch nochmal an der
stelle der einschub das jahr zahlreiche
ihrer kollegen auch jetzt gegen diese
maßnahmen klagen alleine in berlin ist
heute sind mehrere dutzend teil anträge
eingegangen
können sie das nachvollziehen
befürworten sie dass diese klagewelle
sozusagen
ja wir sehen ja gratis dilemma
das heißt was wir in den letzten wochen
und monaten tun spalte die gesellschaft
es geht jung gegen alt ging die die sich
daran gehalten haben die nicht das geht
gegen kleine familien gegen große
familien es geht die die homeschooling
machen müssen und home office haben
gegen die anderen also ist fühlt sich in
der gesellschaft im moment nicht sehr
gut an weil sich jeder irgendwo in die
andere richtung hin zeigt und tut und
macht und natürlich ist die logik
dahinter zu sagen ich hole mir jetzt vom
gericht noch einmal einen durch einen
eilantrag die situation dass wir öffnen
können das verstehe ich und jetzt kommt
natürlich der nächsten moment dazu der
sich wahrscheinlich in den nächsten 24
stunden dann auch als lösung auch
darstellen kann denn wenn natürlich von
altmaier und co diese wirtschafts
unterstützenden maßnahmen mit 70
beziehungsweise 75 prozent wirklich
greifen dann müssen wir sagen na gut
okay so ganz lassen sie uns nicht im
regen stehen das problem es hilft uns
noch nichts weil die frage ist wie
wie kommen wir aus der sache er wieder
raus also es macht ja was mit den
menschen wenn du sagst jetzt gehen wir
mal nicht essen
da gibt es die einen die das nicht immer
die anderen die das wirklich ein herz
und seele mitnehmen und die dann auch
blockiert sind und wir müssen wieder
zurückkommen und dass das ganze wieder
anläuft wie schnell wie gut in welche
richtung das ist natürlich mit einem
ständer das heißt das gesamtkonstrukt
ist bei weitem nicht so einfach und es
lässt sich natürlich nicht so einfach
erklären und auch die wirtschaftlichen
folgen jetzt auch darstellen und
ernsthaft zehn milliarden unterstützung
ich habe die selber mal in einem
einfachen realschulen moment ein
bisschen hochgerechnet ich glaube nicht
dass das für so viel betriebe wirklich
reicht wie man eigentlich angedeutet hat
wir reden auch gleich noch mal über die
zehn milliarden beziehungsweise über die
unterstützung die es gibt wollen vorher
nochmal die kanzlerin mit ins boot holen
sozusagen denn sie hat ja heute die
pressekonferenz gegeben und sie hat auch
gesagt dass sich die bundesregierung
diese entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht
habe dass das ganze große opfer verlange
das sei ihr schon bewusst wir hören noch
mal rein was sie genau gesagt hat ich
weiß dass viele restaurants geschäfte
und betriebe ja große anstrengungen
unternommen haben und uns das fanden die
bedingungen arbeiten zu können und das
sind vorkehrungen die noch sehr wertvoll
sein werden wenn er nämlich wieder in
einer etwas freie zeit hinein gehen
können aber im augenblick wegen der 75
prozent nicht mehr zuordnen waren
infektionen und wegen der absoluten
notwendigkeit kontakte zu reduzieren
können diese hygienemaßnahmen nicht ihre
wirkung entfallen also das problem ist
bei 75 prozent der aktuellen infizierten
weiß man nicht genau wo sie sich
angesteckt haben oder man weiß es gar
nicht und deswegen müsse jetzt gehandelt
sprich geschlossen werden
ich sehe da bei ihnen widerspruch ja und
zwar in der hinsicht vor noch einem
halben jahr wenn das rkw gesagt hat in
diese richtung müssen wir gehen sind
alle blind gefolgt jetzt sagt das rp
also restaurants hotels und co sind sind
kein kein detail das heißt also für die
infektions situation laut lka
sind wir das nicht aber um die bewegung
in der gesellschaft einzudämmen sind wie
es schon da sieht man mal wieder die
systemrelevanz der gastronomie sagen wir
mal folgendes die gastronomie ist auch
etwas die wirklich viel kraft hat das
heißt die forderung jetzt von merkel und
co an uns und diese ich habe davon schon
gesagt dieses wirtschaftliche
bauernopfer dass wir gerade sind für für
gesamtdeutschland was wir tragen müssen
das lassen wir uns einfach mal so
dahingestellt man muss uns natürlich die
option aufgeben wie kommen wir wieder
daraus das heißt wenn wir so ein teil
sind wenn man versteht wie wir denken
und man muss mal eins ganz klar sagen
diese 2,4 millionen mitarbeiter
die trifft es hart und ich weiß dass er
selber von meinem team hier was glauben
sie was gestern los war ich komm hier
gestern etwas später rein ins hotel hat
sich die kathrin hindern computer so
wissen zusammen gesagt an der rezeption
seit katrin was ist los sagt sie ich bin
total fertig bin so frustriert ich habe
nur stornierungen heute gemacht
gearbeitet das kann doch nicht wahr sein
das heißt es macht was im herzen mit uns
mit den mitarbeitern mit dem team mit
den menschen und diesen menschen müssen
wir entschuldigungen über die politik
auch neuen horizont geben also wenn wir
jetzt so wichtig sind für diese für
diesen brecher also den wellenbrecher
dann möchte ich aber auch bietet das
wenn wir da wieder rauskommt dass wir im
gegenzug auch unterstützung bekommen und
zwar hilfe zur selbsthilfe
ich würde einfach mal weiterhin
unterstützen dass der durchaus erst
eingeschlagene weg der regierung durch
steuererleichterungen die gastronomie
einfach auch zu unterstützen wir
brauchen rückenwind wir brauchen die
möglichkeit dass man uns mal mit
bürokratischen momenten so entlastet und
auch von mir abgaben da kann man
durchaus mal darüber reden dass wir
wirklich es schaffen wieder nach vorne
gehen zu können dass wir das licht es
ist ein tunnel und am ende des tunnel
brennt ein licht und es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten es ist der ausgang wo wir
ins helle kommen oder es ist der
entgegenkommenden zug und sogar noch
platt macht und deswegen hätte ich gerne
frau merkel und co bedenken dass dieses
licht am ende des tunnels für
etwas stalin das haben soll weil dann
gehen wir durch diese dunkelheit auch
durch aber jetzt brauchen wir mehr als
nur mir schauen wir mal die nächsten
vier wochen
die kanzlerin hat allerdings dazu auch
noch gesagt dass es momentan ja gar
nicht so sehr um die hygiene konzepte
gehe sondern alleine darum oder in
erster linie darum kontakte generell zu
vermeiden und dazu zählen eben auch dann
die schließung von gaststätten überzeugt
sie das gar nicht ja das habe ich ja
verstanden
das habe ich ja verstanden und ich kann
diesen diese denkweise kann ich
natürlich folgen
und ich kann natürlich auch folgen und
das ist auch etwas was uns in der
gastronomie natürlich auch hilft es
macht ja keinen sinn alles wieder
zuzumachen
weil dann kommen dann dauert es noch
länger bis wir alle wieder hochkommen
der punkt ist einfach nur dass man
verstehen muss dass wir mit dem was wir
tun durchaus in der lage sind auch
kontrolliert eben mit der gesellschaft
umzugehen
denn wenn man uns zu macht gibt es immer
noch die gegenbewegungen die
gegenbewegung heißt die menschen feiern
zu hause die menschen bleiben vielleicht
auch zu hause aber sie treffen sich zu
hause und jetzt muss ich wieder rkh
nehmen und dort passieren die meisten
ansteckungen also dass die frage immer
sich doch mal stellen muss hat man
vielleicht mache ich mal eine beweis
umkehr insofern dass ich sagt jetzt
lassen uns mal offen
aber jetzt gehen wir halt mal her und
ordnungsamt und greift auch wirklich
durch denn das verrückte ist ja wenn
schon im heißen herd geboten wenn jetzt
bestraft wegen den anderen die das
überzogen am wahrung ist da dann die man
da der die auch wirklich ermahnt es gibt
es ja sieht man auch immer wieder von
mir aus in hamburg hier im kiez und so
weiter dass da durchaus durchgegriffen
wurde und dann hat sich das auch
verbessert es gibt es in verschiedenen
herrmann ich hatte da gerade deshalb
sollte man sich in sachen die den punkt
habe ich jetzt verstanden also sie sind
der ansicht dass sozusagen die wenn denn
dann schon weiter sich getroffen wird
sie gehen davon aus dass die leute das
weiter machen werden ist ja auch die
frage in welchem maße das dann
tatsächlich stattfindet aber wenn dann
wäre das ihrer ansicht nach besser
sozusagen in der gastronomie wo sie auf
die abstände usw einwirken
können wäre es eine alternative gewesen
schreibt uns über youtube bumblebee sex
wäre es eine alternative gewesen
die restaurants offen zu lassen aber
ohne alkohol verkauft wie stehen sie
dieser frage gegenüber
also ich verstehe die diskussion um das
thema alkohol
aber es geht ja nicht generell darum
sondern es geht natürlich um die menge
und es geht in welchem umfeld ich glaube
nicht dass in einem klassischen
restaurant bistro von mir aus kaffee und
co das dass das große thema ist ich
verstehe auch dass man sagt lasst uns
mal bitte darüber nachdenken um 22 uhr
schluss zu machen und lasst uns darüber
nachdenken das sind eben nicht größere
ansammlungen in den straßen und so
weiter sind die sich alle ihre eigene
flasche mitbringt das verstehe ich schon
deswegen sage ich ja lieber im
kontrollierten kontrollierten umfeld
denn selbst wenn jemand bei mir jetzt
sage mal oder wo auch immer in der
gastronomie den zetteln vielleicht nicht
mit den absolut richtigen angaben
ausfüllt von mir aus auch mal 20 prozent
was sehr hohe summe wäre dann sind aber
immer noch 80 prozent richtig wenn ich
jetzt das nicht mache und die leute sich
trotzdem treffen wie sie wollen dann
habe ich aber 0% wo ich wirklich
nachvollziehen kann
und wenn jemand also ich weiß nicht ich
stelle mir das so vor
du hast dich privat getroffen mit der
familie mit freunden und dann stellt
sich vielleicht nach einer woche oder so
raus du bist corona positiv greift dann
der zum hörer und ruft seine freunde und
familie an und sagt läutet vielleicht
müsst ihr euch alle mal testen ich
bezweifle dass der manche durchaus auch
sagen sie schämen sich und sie wollen
nichts sagen dass dann irgendeiner weise
irgendwas wo war also das ist schon
etwas das dürfen wir nicht diese
psychologie dürfen wir nicht dürfen wir
nicht ganz außer acht lassen ist
vielleicht ein bisschen her gespinst
aber es ist eher so eine tief sitzende
angst die ich damit ausdrücken möchte
wir wollen noch mal die kanzlerin zu
wort kommen lassen würden nochmal reine
angela merkel heute bei der
pressekonferenz zu der frage welche
probleme insbesondere eben bei
gastronomiebetrieben auftreten und
warum gerade dort die schließungen
zumindest nach meinung der
bundesregierung sinnvoll sind
das heißt wir haben uns sehr gut
überlegt wo reduzieren der kontakt aber
auch das habe ich ja versucht zu sagen
auch in einem konzertsaal auch in einem
restaurant wo die tische auf 15 meter
abstand stehen oder die menschen auf 15
meter abstand sitzen müssen die menschen
in das konzert fahren ich habe also bei
der anfahrt bei der abfahrt beim
sprechen innerhalb in vor und nach der
veranstaltung oder weil ich nicht
kontrollieren kann ob 234 haushalte an
einem tisch sitzen wo er natürlich nicht
die ganze zeit überprüft werden kann wie
viele menschen kommen da zusammen die
fahren dann alle wieder nach hause und
gehen in ihre familien hinein
all das müssen wir jetzt unterbinden
weil wir zu hoch sind bei den
infektionen
also das sind gleich noch mal mehrere
probleme angesprochen worden zum einen
liegen eine fehlende nachprüfbarkeit von
angaben beziehungsweise sie können nicht
kontrollieren das werden sie
wahrscheinlich auch schon erlebt haben
in ihrem betrieb ob da jetzt tatsächlich
personen aus zwei oder aus mehr
haushalten zusammen sitzen und dann
natürlich auch die frage
das schreibt uns auch zum beispiel fred
vom jupiter über facebook das ist ja
eben auch nicht nur um die veranstaltung
vor ort geht sondern auch um die an- und
abreise also das sind alles probleme
ich verstehe den gedankengang dahinter
ich bezweifle dass es alleine so nur
wirken kann
weil nach wie vor ich mir schon klar
dass man jetzt versucht die
gesellschaftliche bewegung einzudämmen
das ist selbstverständlich so und wir
sind insofern systemrelevant für die
bewegung der gesellschaft weil wir zum
nennen was man so durchaus schöne
momente des tages dazu gehören essen
trinken gehen sich zusammensetzen das
gesellschaftliche leben und das wird
natürlich also chapeau und leicht
süffisant und sarkastisch wird das
natürlich so über den staat durchaus
kommt dank high line
aber es ist eben genau die frau
wie kommen wir wieder da raus ich möchte
jetzt nicht diskutieren wir richtig oder
falsch mal was ist sondern was ist jetzt
der schritt danach ist es wirklich der
erste zwölfte wohl wieder loslegen
können der 15 der zwölfte ist es der
erste erste der 15 die erste und was
kommt danach wie möchte man wenn wir als
gastronomie hotellerie die künstler und
co wenn wir jetzt sagen okay wir sind
jetzt die branchen die für deutschland
dafür gesorgt haben dass jetzt dieser
wellenbrecher auch stattfinden kann
dass der funktioniert dann möchte ich
bitte um das ist mit bitte ist
unterstrichen eine chance haben das wäre
ein signal bekommen wie können wir das
ganze auch für uns als branche wieder
raus sie wollen eine exit-strategie
aufgezeigt bekommen genau ich glaube
dieser punkt ist deutlich geworden
wir wollen noch mal über die aktuelle
jetzt über den november sprechen die
aktuelle situation insgesamt werden ja
von der bundesregierung es wurde bei uns
gerade auch schon thematisiert zehn
milliarden euro zur verfügung gestellt
für die wirtschaft und da stellt sich
doch die frage wie genau wirkt sich das
aus einzelheiten dazu von meinem
kollegen antoine kurschilgen damit
betriebe wie restaurants und bars nicht
pleite gehen will die bundesregierung
ihnen ordentlich unter die arme greifen
solo selbständige und kleine unternehmen
mit bis zu 50 mitarbeitern sollen 75
prozent des umsatzes aus einem monat
erstattet bekommen
entscheidend dafür ist der umsatz vom
november 2009 10 bei jungen unternehmen
die nach november 2009 10 gegründet
wurden gelten die umsätze von oktober
2020 als maßstab größere betriebe sollen
bis zu 70 prozent erstattet bekommen
das gilt für alle die im november dicht
machen müssen also unter anderem
restaurants bars kneipen fitnessstudios
theater kinos und auch konzerthäuser
insgesamt sollen dafür zehn milliarden
euro bereit gestellt werden
tja also hermann 75 prozent des umsatzes
von november 2009 10 sind die betriebe
auch die gastronomischen betriebe dank
dieser hilfen nicht für den moment mal
relativ gut aufgestellt
definitiv also die 70 beziehungsweise 75
prozent sind etwas damit wird bin ich
der meinung jeder gastronom zumindest
diese phase überwinden was nichts daran
aendert ist natürlich auch meine bitte
was kommt trotzdem danach also hilfe zur
selbsthilfe ich finde wir sollten nicht
mehr bekommen sondern wir sollen
möglichkeiten bekommen aber nicht ganz
kurze sie an der stelle weitere einmal
ganz kurz unterbrechen wollen weil mich
das wirklich interessiert uns
interessiert auch einige unserer user
wie wäre denn die situation jetzt für
sie wenn es jetzt eben diese 75 prozent
nicht gebe von november 2009 10 sondern
sie hätten jetzt ganz normal eben den
umsatz den sie nun mal haben mit
abstandsregeln mit dem entsprechenden
leerlauf ist das nicht sogar eine
besserstellung kann ich ihnen sagen nein
das ist eben leider falsch erst einmal
muss ich noch einmal zurück das heißt
der bis zu 75% und wenn der staat sagt
bis zu dann heißt immer auflagen dann
heißt es in der regel immer dinge die du
bringen muss und die 75 prozent dann zu
bekommen musst du meistens wirklich
wahnsinnig dafür dafür leisten oder oder
also die 75 ist als höchstmarke schon
mal gut aber dadurch dass wir in den
letzten wochen und monaten gearbeitet
haben mit wir als als gastronomie als
team ich darf sagen wir haben es
geschafft dass unsere betriebe so
aufgestellt sind dass wir zum beispiel
zwei meetings machen konnten
das bedeutet dass wir alle gäste die
kommen wollten durchaus auch bewirken
konnten und durch die zwei siege also um
18 29 uhr also reserviert sein damit
haben wir zwei sachen schaffen können
jeder konnte kommen die geringere tisch
zeit konnten wir auffangen
wir konnten jedes mal immer lüften
hygiene machen durch diese zwei stunden
war auch die zeit wo man bleiben kann
auch reduziert das bedeutet man sagt ja
immer ab zwei stunden wird gefühlt
gefährlich das bedeutet wir waren auf
einem guten weg im gegenteil wir haben
zwar doppelt so viel arbeiten müssen so
hat sich auch alle verlernt wir mussten
wahnsinnig viel tun dafür die gäste
haben mit wahnsinnig vielen verständnis
rekrutiert und ich darf sagen dass der
november umsatz 2009 10 im verhältnis
zur 2020 ich glaube wir werden um
einiges darüber gelegen und zwar ich
möchte das betonen warum weil man uns
auch und dafür möchte ich auch danke an
die bundesregierung sagen schon ein
zeichen der selbsthilfe gegeben hat weil
die mehrwertsteuer änderung gegen helfen
hat verstehe also es wäre besser gewesen
auch langfristig helfen ja es wäre nicht
besser gewählt ja alles gebaut 2020 ist
wie gesagt ohne diese auflagen jetzt
gewesen wäre das nicht aber sie erkennen
an dass die hilfen in höhe bis zu 75
prozent von november 2009 10 immerhin
auch nicht nicht sind das habe ich auch
deutlich bei ihnen raus setzen wird
da muss man ganz klar sagen das hilft
schon da darf man nicht meckern da muss
man sagen die regierung hat sich dabei
was gedacht so ist es nicht das heißt
natürlich nicht dass ich deswegen tief
enttäuscht bin also sie merken schon bei
mir sehr herz und hören das spricht ja
beides das eine sind heute und das
andere ist schon zum teil auch ein ganz
gewiss und klares verständnis dafür und
ich verstehe auch was die regierung uns
anbietet aber ich möchte einfach auch in
dem fall auch mehr für seele und auch
für den unternehmerischen sicherheits
moment allem darum bitten in der
regierung zusammen ich würde gerne über
das paket nach diesem blog downlight
nachdenken ja gibt es uns insofern hilfe
zur selbsthilfe senkt ein paar steuern &
co ist angekommen zumindest hier bei uns
alexander kraut fragt über facebook
nicht in einem restaurant essen gehen zu
können ist ein luxusproblem liefer und
abholservice sind ja nach wie vor
gestattet wie viel macht dass ihres
geschäftes aus und ist das ein trost
also wir haben das ja sehr aktiv im märz
ein bisschen loslegt april und mai haben
wir das sehr aktiv gelebt ich habe ja
zwei locations des eines auf dem land
wirsberg das andere stadt nürnberg man
merkt da klare unterschiede zwischen
stadt und land wie was funktioniert aber
abholen und liefern ist natürlich
liefern zb in der stadt interessanter
abholen es auf dem land genauso gut aber
erst am schluss
geht ein daraus dass du am wochenende
damit ein bisschen umsatz machen kannst
das ist mehr innerbetriebliche
mitarbeiter seelsorge und auch als
unternehmer dass du das gefühl hast wir
bleiben in bewegung so ein klassisches
hotel wie wir jetzt hier in württemberg
sind es ist wie ein altes schlachtschiff
wenn du vin diesel ab schaltet dann
brauchst du den kriegst du immer in
schwung deswegen ist es gut für die
bewegung zu sorgen aber wenn wir wenn es
gut läuft haben wir zehn prozent des
umsatzes und mehr nicht und zehn prozent
kann man sich ausrechnen
verstehe ich vielleicht noch mal um das
bild ein bisschen abzurunden noch die
frage inwieweit sie da einblicke haben
franken schreibt über facebook was ist
mit der begleit und zulieferer industrie
der gastronomie die ist gleich zehnmal
größer als die gastro branche selbst wie
sieht es da aus
er hat zum beispiel mal ein beispiel
dieses jahr wir bestellen logischerweise
für dezember unsere gänse immer bei
unserem händler vor dass man sagen wir
werden so und so viele gänse ca
verarbeiten der ganze brauchen bitte wir
wollen bei wert aus dem entsprechenden
hohen auch anspruch an das produkt haben
und es war zum beispiel relativ
schwierig auch eine gewisse menge zu
bekommen weil ja schon arm im frühjahr
viele zulieferer gesagt haben wir werden
nicht so viele gänse dieses jahr
wahrscheinlich abnehmen können
das heißt also man hat hier auch gesagt
wir werden dann zuviel züchten
jetzt ist natürlich die ironie des
schicksals jetzt habe ich sie trotzdem
übrig jetzt schauen wir mal wie man wie
man diese gänse wie wir die natürlich
noch weiterhin artgerecht sag ich mal an
die menschheit bringen denn ja wir
werden es wahrscheinlich liefern um
abholen aber man merkt schon dass die
das die zulieferer die hinter uns quasi
stehen und darauf warten dass wir
abnehmen
die trifft es natürlich genau so dass es
gar keine frage also wir sind mit
unseren 2,4 millionen mitarbeiter mit
diesen 200.000 betrieb die wir sind wir
sind schon ein ziemlich großer hebel
innerhalb von deutschland das merkt man
nicht dass es so ein kleines feines
geflecht der sich durch die ganze
republik durchziehen weil man bei uns
ein wenig in die störfaktoren so
eindringt dann hat es extreme
auswirkungen und dementsprechend müssen
wir alle miteinander mit unserer branche
und branchen- auch die in der künstler
feinfühlig umgehen letzte frage was
wünschen sie sich von der
bundesregierung wenn sie denn einen
wunsch äußern durften so zu sagen was
würden sie sich wünschen von der
bundesregierung ab dem dezember dann ich
muss insofern natürlich auch ein
kompliment loswerden
und ich weiß das mag in dem fall
zwischen kakas tisch werden wenn ich
rückblickend in den ersten lockdown
hinschauen
da hat uns unsere regierung
vorbildlichen gesamteuropa genauso auch
agiert dass danach das ganze ein
bisschen lasch war das ist das trifft
uns jetzt umso härter und ja ich habe
keine lust dass wir jetzt der
wirtschafts moment sind und wir müssen
das alles ein bisserl rausreißen
das trifft mich sehr das zeigt
vielleicht auch wie ich systemrelevant
wir sind wir kriegen dadurch vielleicht
neun stempel der wichtigkeit in allen
ihren sarkasmus ich hätte mir gewünscht
wir kriegen den so nicht aber bitte gibt
uns einen weg einen plan aus diesem
tunnel heraus dass dieses licht wirklich
dann hell auch wieder scheinen kann auf
die gastronomie das sind so viele
existenzen dran so viel menschen die mit
viel leidenschaft gastronomie
funktioniert über leidenschaft und
hingabe
das ist ähnlich wie in den
krankenhäusern altenpflege theater und
co das sind leidenschaft getrieben
unternehmen und die brauchen auch so
eine leidenschaftliche tür dass man sagt
wir lassen euch nicht alleine weil wir
sind nunmal dienstleistungen wir sind
keine industrie wir brauchen ein wenig
wenn ich jetzt das dumm sagt dann muss
ich sagen mitgefühl das wirkt der bisse
leibern aber das ist vom herz und sollte
ins hirn gehen ein emotionaler appel
noch mal von ihnen zum schluss alexander
herrmann war das sternekoch und
gastronomen aus oberfranken hotelier ist
auch vielen dank für das gespräch mit
uns heute abend
danke sehr dankeschön und uns erreicht
eine eilmeldung wir bekommen den hinweis
die information dass ist in wien an
einer synagoge
einen großeinsatz der polizei gibt dort
sollen schüsse gefallen seien in der
zdf- heute- app halten wir euch auf dem
laufenden genau natürlich auch für die
kollegen vom heute journal das ganze
heute wie gewohnt um 21 uhr 45 alles
weitere dazu dann dort euch noch mal ein
ja auch großes dankeschön fürs zuschauen
und auch fürs mitmachen für die frage
und die kommentare
wir wünschen euch noch einen schönen
abend und sagen danke bis zum nächsten
mal